voici ce qu'il reste de l'immeuble visé
par l'armée russe à kiev dimanche
les trois derniers étages sont
pulvérisés à l'intérieur les secouristes
découvrent un corps sans vie il s'agit
d'un homme de 37 ans sa fille de 7 ans
elle a été blessée
ce quartier résidentiel et bombardé pour
la troisième fois depuis le début de la
guerre le président zelensky menace les
russes de représailles c'est l'autre
dispute tous les colloques ordinateur
mécaniciens aux personnes qui assurent
le lancement de ces missiles sur
l'ukraine doivent comprendre
nous avons tous vous retrouver chacun
d'entre vous on sera tenu responsable de
ces frais se donnait gain à
400 km de la capitale à kharkiv une zone
résidentielle a également été prise pour
cible on ne compte plus les voitures
calcinées
les maisons sont dévastés cet homme a
failli rester bloqué sous les gravats
nous avons creusé autant que nous avons
qu mais nos jambes étaient prises au
piège par les décombres les sauveteurs
sont arrivés rapidement avec tous les
équipements nécessaires
on a passé environ une heure sous les
décombres
autre front celui du donbass les forces
russes ont pu pénétrer dans la ville de
l'iscid shank la raffinerie a subi
d'importants dégâts avec ses frappes la
russie rappelle sa capacité à atteindre
n'importe quel point du territoire
ukrainien
histoire de mettre un peu plus la
pression sur les dirigeants du g7 alliés
de kiev
réunis au sommet de munich